la marge politique
vous êtes le numéro un
bah ça fait
bonjour non la deuxième semaine est
numéro un loin devant les autres
on a fait pratiquement le double doublé
2e g comptant remald il fait toujours
kafka jusqu'au moins que c'est dur
dimanche effet la matinée alors quand il
entend le samedi c'est surtout il fait
samedi deux fois samedi de pas dire on
n'en dort pas dans la nuit du samedi
c'est terrible va bosser sur un outil ou
alors est-ce que vous allez partir en
vacances au maroc et à bayou
ça va et on disparaît
carrément tu as pu faire de
seine-et-marne
non
dans son bain je sais pas mais moi
j'aime bien j'aime bien cette intrigue
mais juste parce que je savais pas si on
va proposer des choses
tu sais pas si tu as la foi
la foi la foi en dieu non la fois
cinématographique
c'est pas non
m
c'est à gonfler de faire la promo comme
ça de faire des interviews je n'ai pas
pu beaucoup n'ont pas fait réel à la
télé tu as fait quoi et puis c'est tout
mais je traversais
les faits
ouais un truc qui est bien avec toi
c'est que tout le monde te parles de ton
grand père comme ça et sable orné tu
aimes bien qu'on va faire je le connais
pas très bien
on parle tout le temps de son grand père
louis seigner n'en parle jamais de ton
père qu'est ce qui fait qu'en terre
il est normal les acteurs sont pas
normaux
pourrait-on pas voulu leur dire ton âge
à elle comme ça ces femmes deux ans
c'est pas mieux commencer par 22h sur
internet à 20h non j'ai fait une gaffe à
la main c'est pas si c'est parce que
dans le dossier de presse de marquise a
remarqué 22 c'est pour ça qu'elle a
voulu dire non c'est pas pour ça s'est
passé
la manière dont tu demande est restée
plus rigolo c'est aimer quand inconnu
romane tu avais déjà fait le film avec
godard était détective qui vous agréent
ce qu'a dit ce que je faisais c'est
parce qu'on fait tu faisais la pub et
ferhat stéphane c'est vrai que narita
dicte
va faire du cinéma porno c'est un joli
cul de bien fait de pas les compter
après tu as fait le film de gagner de
faire comment ça s'est passé
en fait un jour il m'a appelé chez moi
et il m'a demandé d'où il m'a donné le
scénario m'a dit si tu veux le faire
alors comme c'était facile et pas de
casting
je lui donne pas trop de compliqué mais
là non moi je fais si si ça vient sinon
je vais pas chercher ses cours privés le
film hsa et alors après tu as connu
rendre à ce moment là non non j'ai connu
one c'est lui qui t'a dit de passer le
bac et de la danse à qousseir il m'a
fait passer le bac il m'a envoyé en
angleterre pour apprendre l'anglais et
puis c'est un vrai big man ont été
quittes il indiqué ouais c'est bien
c'est bien c'est un vrai bygmalion tu as
eu peur au début quand tu la rencontre
est la cause de sa réputation bas au
début je sais pas le premier jour je
vais aller chez lui j'avais peur qu'il
ya la drogue dans le champagne parce
qu'on qualifie oui je suis moi j'ai pas
entendu avant les réponses étaient tous
trois sets
devenu le champagne quand même et après
s'est passé après tu as vu qu'il n'était
pas apprécié
[Musique]
ce avec génial
la fin
et le tournage de frontier que c'était
dur pas vraiment c'est vrai qu'il ya
c'est lui qui a dit que tu avais donné
seulement 40 % de ce que tu pouvais
donner ou recevoir c'est lui pourtant je
sais pas mais il dit que j'étais pas mal
de films d'aujourd'hui donnera sans
conscience à ce stade je ne peux pas te
donner tout de suite non mais disons que
j'avais une attitude pendant un tournage
c'était un petit peu que je mélange est
un peu la vie privée et leur travail
alors quelquefois j'arrivais sur le
plateau en lui faisant la gueule parce
que j'avais piqué mes chaussettes je
sais pas quoi et ça m'a empêché de
travailler parce que je mélange est
toutefois de connaître les techniciens
du point ouais je reconnais tout le
temps je pensais qu'à rigaux ouais ça
l'énervé il avait la responsabilité de
filtrer l'eau qui disait que c'était
certes mais pas ça vous êtes beaucoup
discuté à l'époque du film
maintenant ça va mieux maintenant ça va
très bien depuis deux mois
a été payé combien votre fric cher non
je ne suis pas arnaquer même si robben
le réalisateur il s'était fait remarquer
c'est à dire bah
trente six mille francs pas beaucoup et
j'ai vécu une belle feinte de frappe a
quand même tag hull et tafer la grève
quand j'ai gueulé parce que je stresse
étaient passés mardi
bien il sonne fort d'être bien alors une
incroyable j'aime à dire non à nivea
truc énorme envie de te marier trois
mâles va se marier avant on a décidé on
va se marier parce que les taux pourquoi
à ce collège parce qu'elle va aller
voter pour la terre
ouais et on a décidé qu'on va sauver la
barque de l'avant et c'est réglé
l'affairé dans le sac
moi j'ai envie de me marier en retard et
sans escale
j'aimerais bien ça ça je te prends la
différence d'âge ce n'est pas un
problème
ben non il à ce jeune espoir répit
ça va y avoir des enfants
j'ai pas pour l'instant je compense
attention il est là non je peux battre
il est revenue la pause il a enfin
arrêté et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous il
m'était impossible eux